REMAIN ANONYMOUS AND THAT WE
ALTER HIS VOICE.
>> Translator: LOOK AT HIS
CLOTHES HE'S NOT IRAQI.
I'S NOT HIS REAL NAME SPEAKING
TO US ON CONDITION THAT WE
CONCEAL HIS IDENTITY.
HIS WIFE AND CHILDREN ARE STILL
IN THE COUNTRY AND COULD BE
SLAUGHTERED.
HE'S WANTED BY ISIS JUST ESCAPED
WITH THIS VIDEO HE FILMED ON HIS
PHONE.
>> ARE YOU SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
GO FROM MOS L TO BAGHDAD TO
JERUSALEM AND SAID HE WAS
SPEAKING IN BROKEN ARABIC.
THE EXPERIENCES AND THE IMAGES
GIVE US A RARE GLIMPSE INTO THE
MURKY WORLD OF ISIS AND HOW IT
SOLIDIFIED ITS GRASP.
>> THE KID IS GETTING THE ISIS
FIGHTER A KISS.
SOME OF THE WOMEN WERE EVEN
THROWING CHOCOLATE ON THEM AND
SHOUTING, YOU SAVED US FROM THE
SEEK TARN ARMY, FROM MALIKI'S
ARMY.
IT'S BECAUSE THE ARMY HAD HARMED
THE PEOPLE, PUT TOO MUCH
PRESSURE ON THEM.
IT'S THOSE ACTIONS THAT TURNED
THE TERRORISTS INTO HEROES.
THE PEOPLE WILL BE BETRAYED.
ALREADY ISIS IS IMPLEMENTING ITS
HARSH INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW.
WHEN WHO WEAR THREE-QUARTER
PANTS GET LASHED, HE SAYS.
IF THERE WAS INTERNET YOU WOULD
SEE THE WORST OF THEIR TORTURE.
WOMEN CAN'T GO OUT WITHOUT A
MALE GUARDIAN.
AND HE IS STILL SHOCKED HIS CITY
FELL SO FAST.
THERE WERE ONLY TWO TO THREE
HUNDRED ISIS FIGHTERS AND 40 TO
50,000 IRAQI SECURITY FORCES.
BUT AFTER FIGHTING FOR THREE
DAYS, THEY DISAPPEARED, HE SAYS.
>> THIS IS FROM THE SPECIAL
OPERATIONS FOR THE
ANTI-TERRORISM UNIT.
>> AFTER MOVING THROUGH, SLEEPER
CELLS ARE ACTIVATED.
THEY ARE IRAQI.
ALL THE GROUPS THAT WERE
FIGHTING THE AMERICANS AT THE
START ARE NOW BACK AND WITH
ISIS, HE EXPLAINS.
MALIKI'S ACTIONS ARE FUELING THE
FIRE.
AMERICAN BOMBING WOULD WRECK
MORE HAVOC THAN THERE ALREADY
IS.
HE PAUSES, HIS VOICE STARTS TO
CRACK.
THE COUNTRY IS DESTROYED.
IT'S LOST, HE SAYS,
DISBELIEVING.
AFTER A THOUSAND YEARS IT WON'T
COME BACK.
HIS EYES FILL WITH TEARS AS HE
ADDS, THE CITY OF MOZ L, ONCE
THE CITY OF PROFITS, IN A DAY
AND NIGHT IT TURNED INTO A CITY
OF GOETS AND NIGHTMARES.
>> Reporter: AND HE BELIEVES
THAT THERE HAS TO BE SOME SORT
OF POLITICAL CHANGE, THAT MALIKI
MOST DEFINITELY NEEDS TO GO.
BUT HE DID NOT BELIEVE THAT'S
GOING TO HELP SAVE HIS COUNTRY.
BUT AT THE VERY LEAST IT COULD
BEGIN TO EASE SOME OF THE
TENSIONS, PERHAPS EVEN CAUSE
SOME OF THE VIOLENCE TO SUBSIDE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY HE
SAYS WHAT PEOPLE REALLY NEED TO